[Music]
atomic blonde so atomic blonde it'll dot
the movie it takes place in the late 80s
during the fall of the Berlin Wall
it's kind of a stylistic spy thriller
it's not really the she John wick you
might have heard this movie is a star
Charlize Theron it's like the best of
the best and there's a list of names of
spies that it begins out there well
threaten the lives of all the spies yeah
you've heard this blob before I think
dozen there are dozens if not hundreds
of spy movies with this premise so she
runs across James McAvoy really
convoluted plot in there and basically
trying to get the listening right so
what I like James McAvoy dude it's just
that you can be in the shittiest movies
ever it was still like yeah but he was
good in the mag of what crushes it he
kills it he's great in his movie and
sofia boutella we actually see a little
more from her not gonna lie until this
movie she was the contortionist she's
either a contortionist with sword legs
or she's a contortionist mummy very few
lines is when she gives a bit more
Charlize Theron was solid kick-ass - who
is a parent she trained - there's a
scene where she puts his turtleneck up
over her nose and mouth and then she's
throwing down with these dudes and I was
like okay so it's a stunt person the
turtleneck up over the face is how they
can keep you from being able to tell in
one shot the fight is done and then she
pulls it down it's actually Charlize
Theron's color me impressed it was
actually really cool and I like the
movies use of music during scenes and
action seeking there's some of it
unexpected but it's fun to put
unexpected music to a shootout or an
action scene and have it work issues
that should with doom all the time on
xbox I was just put on that track from
the five six seven eighths from Kill
Bill come stupid reason it's fun to kill
demons of that song it's really does a
bit of that I thought that was fun and
there is a hallway action sequence which
I can say someone probably saw daredevil
season 2 was like alright I want to
stairwell action scene a lot like that
but more bloody and here we got it
that's seen as savage it's great rest of
the movie is pretty boring forgettable
stylistic sure but it's a spy movie
you've seen a hundred times before it
tries to be too clever for its own good
in the lead-up of this movie I was like
oh this movie might be like snatch 2017
here we got another snatch s kind of
movie not snatched but snacks but among
the fun music and the gripe McAvoy I
movie this is kind of a boring spy mash
this really has like four different
endings works if you're there for a 12
hour epic yeah couple hours I don't need
at least one of these endings feels
tacked
until like alright the movies Iraq I
think you could go for one more really
funny some of the people thought the
movie was over left it lacks the movies
our reviewers these are critics and they
are reviewing this movie now without all
the information that just cracked me up
honestly see for a movie like this to
work it needs to focus on I get spy
movies want to have a lot of twists and
turns but don't have too many twists and
turns don't have too many branches don't
have too many spiderwebs but this movie
had so many branches of things that was
trying to do that really it didn't do
anything and all to stop the list from
getting out all to stop the plot of a
hundred other spy movies that just did
it better which is a bummer this movie
had focused up it can have the same plot
of a bunker for the spy movies being the
list and all but it would have been a
fun stylistic take on it as we have it
we just kind of have a forgettable wreck
I'll say I'm probably not going to
remember atomic blonde at t-minus one
day yep already forgot all right guys so
atomic belong to have you seen it what
did you think about it what's your
favorite stylistic spy thriller whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]